Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Bonsoir - ah, c’est un petit peu fort !
Bonsoir, merci d’être là.
On m’a donc demandé
de venir vous parler du darknet.
Le fameux darknet, cet endroit sombre
qui fait la joie
des journalistes sensationnalistes,
et qui fait l’objet
de tellement de désinformation.
Qu’est-ce que c’est que le darknet ?
Ce n’est pas ce que l’on vous présente,
c’est tout à fait autre chose.
Je vais commencer par vous expliquer
ce qu’est un darknet.
Vous savez, sur Internet,
vous n’êtes absolument pas anonyme.
Grâce à votre fameuse adresse IP
dont vous avez tant entendu parler,
il est possible de vous tracer : votre
fournisseur d’accès sait parfaitement
ce que vous faites sur Internet.
Un darknet, c’est tout simplement
un protocole réseau
qui va utiliser Internet
en intégrant nativement
des fonctions d’anonymisation.
Ça veut dire que si vous êtes
sur un darknet,
vous pouvez aller sur Internet,
échanger des fichiers,
aller sur certains sites web, etc.,
ceci sans être identifié.
Le cœur du terme « darknet »,
c’est bien cette notion d’anonymat.
À la différence de l’internet ouvert,
quand vous êtes sur un darknet,
vous êtes anonyme.
Comment ça marche ?
Passons sur les détails
techniques de peu d’intérêt,
je vous explique simplement
le principe général
pour la simple raison que ça fait l’objet
de tellement de fantasmes
qu’il faut comprendre que
le fonctionnement est relativement simple.
Quand vous êtes sur internet normal,
vous allez vous connecter directement
au site de votre quotidien préféré.
Quand vous passez par un darknet,
cette connexion va être indirecte,
elle va passer en fait
par un ensemble de relais intermédiaires,
et grâce à un système de chiffrement,
on fait en sorte
que ces relais ne connaissent
que le prédécesseur et le suivant.
Il est donc absolument impossible ensuite
au nœud de sortie que vous voyez ici
de connaître l’origine de la connexion.
Vous êtes sur un darknet.
Vous êtes censé être anonyme.
Est-ce que le darknet est sûr ?
Est-ce que les darknets sont sûrs ?
Évidemment, ça dépend beaucoup
du darknet que vous utilisez,
mais là, je vais parler du principal
darknet, à savoir le réseau Tor.
Tor, c’est deux millions
d’utilisateurs par jour.
Est-ce que je suis
à l’abri de l’espionnage
quand je suis sur Tor ?
Les révélations Snowden
ont montré que oui, très largement.
En clair, ce que vous voyez ici,
c’est simplement un extrait
d’un document de la NSA
qui a été publié en l’occurrence
par Snowden,
ce document montre que la NSA
est effectivement capable
de désanonymiser les connexions sur Tor.
Mais ce document montre également
... [inaudible]
ce document montre également
que si vous voulez désanonymiser
des connexions Tor,
vous devez, malgré la puissance de la NSA,
- je rappelle que c’est de très loin
la première organisation
de surveillance d’internet au monde,
de très, très loin -
eh bien malgré sa puissance,
si la NSA veut désanonymiser
des relations sur Tor,
elle doit pratiquer de manière manuelle
et relativement laborieuse.
En clair,
soit vous êtes quelqu’un qui est ciblé,
par une grande agence de renseignement
ou par une structure qui a
des moyens techniques avancés,
et effectivement, il est possible
que l’on vous identifie.
Mais si c’est pas le cas,
ce qui est quand même le cas
de l’immense majorité des gens,
quand vous êtes sur un darknet,
a minimum quand vous êtes sur Tor,
oui, vous bénéficiez d’une vraie sécurité.
Des darknets, il y en a plein.
Je vous en présente ici quelques-uns,
des plus représentatifs
et des plus importants,
mais des darknets, il en existe
des dizaines et des dizaines.
Évidemment, Tor, avec ses 2 millions
d’utilisateurs, est de loin le leader.
Tor a une particularité :
c’est que Tor vous permet à la fois
d’accéder à un Internet caché,
c’est le fameux darkweb dont je vais vous
parler rapidement dans quelques minutes,
mais Tor vous permet également d’accéder
au web ouvert de manière anonyme.
Vous êtes en Chine, vous êtes en Russie,
vous êtes dans un pays
qui interdit la connexion à tel ou tel
grand média occidental ou pas occidental.
Si vous passez par Tor, vous allez pouvoir
aller sur le site du Monde,
sur le site du Washington Post
ou sur le site de ce que vous voulez.
Et ceci sans être repéré
par les autorités.
C’est la raison pour laquelle Tor
est de loin l’outil le plus utilisé.
Mais il y en a beaucoup d’autres : Freenet
perd  un petit peu de place en ce moment
en raison de difficulté
d’utilisation mais fonctionne quand même.
J’ai parlé d’i2P, de GNUnet
et de tout un tas d’autres.
Donc il n’y a pas un darknet,
il y a tout un ensemble de darknets,
tout un ensemble de protocoles
qui vous permettent d’aller sur internet,
de communiquer, d’échanger,
de partager des fichiers,
de partager des photos, de tchatter.
Il y a un protocole spécifique qui permet
de tchatter de manière anonyme,
donc à l’abri du regard des autorités.
Lorsque vous connaissez le Tor du darknet,
apparemment, de manière générale,
c’est ce qu’on voit là :
le Darknet, c’est le mal.
Darknet, c’est le mal parce que
sur le darknet, puisqu’on y est anonyme,
se déroulent naturellement des choses
qui sont extrêmement condamnables,
c'est incontestable.
Le fait qu’il existe sur le darknet
des activités absolument abjectes
est une réalité incontestable.
Je prends là quelques exemples :
évidemment, il y a les fameux
supermarchés de la drogue.
Vous avez tous entendu parler
de Silk Road à l’époque, de Alphabet
et de multiples supermarchés de la drogue
et autres d’ailleurs qui ont fleuri
sur le darknet, enfin, sur le darkweb.
Sur ces sites, vous allez pouvoir
trouver des stupéfiants.
Je rappelle quand même que
le principal fournisseur de stupéfiants
dans un pays comme la France,
c’est Instagram et Snapchat, c’est pas ça.
N’en reste pas moins
que vous allez trouver des stupéfiants,
mais également des armes,
vous allez y trouver
des choses assez amusantes.
Amusantes, je sais pas, comme des kits
de changement d’identité.
Vous pouvez commander un kit,
vous envoyez votre photo,
vous allez recevoir en retour
une carte d’identité,
un passeport et éventuellement
de la fausse monnaie.
C’est le genre de choses que vous pouvez
effectivement obtenir de façon simple,
comme si vous fonctionniez sur Amazon.
Les grandes plateformes fonctionnent
exactement comme Amazon,
c’est des market places :
vous, fournisseurs,
venez vous affilier et puis ils prennent
leurs commissions en passant.
Vous pouvez même y trouver,
même si c’est un fake
dans la mesure où aujourd’hui,
on n’a jamais eu de preuve de réalisation,
des offres de services de tueurs à gages,
comme je l’ai montré là.
Pour vous donner une idée de la maturité
de ce type d’environnement,
je vous ai présenté ici une publicité
pour Torshop.
Vous connaissez peut-être PrestaShop.
C’est un outil open source
qui permet à n’importe qui
de monter son magasin en ligne.
Eh bien, il existe
la même chose sur le darkweb.
C’est-à-dire que l’on met
à votre disposition
une sorte de magasin préparé.
Vous n’avez plus qu’à le paramétrer,
à mettre vos produits
dans la vitrine correspondante,
c’est-à-dire que vous n’avez pas besoin
d’être un technicien avancé.
D’ores et déjà,  vous pouvez acheter
des sortes de boutiques toutes faites
pour aller sur le darknet.
Alors oui, effectivement, en ce sens.
le darknet, c’est le mal.
C’est même la seule chose dont
vous entendez parler en général,
à la fois parce que ça,
c’est spectaculaire.
Il est beaucoup plus attrayant
pour un journal de titrer
sur le Darknet, qui est le principal
fournisseur de drogue,
sur l’éventuel achat de prestation
de services d’un tueur à gages
que de titrer sur des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus profondes et [inaudible].
Le Darknet, en fait, c’est
d’abord et avant tout
un outil au service des libertés.
J’ai parlé de Tor, je vous ai beaucoup
parlé de Tor et notamment du darkweb,
cette partie du web qui est sur Tor
où se déroulent
toutes ces activités illégales.
Le darkweb représente quelques pourcents,
on va dire environ 5%
de la bande passante de Tor.
95% de la bande passante
de Tor est utilisée
pour autre chose que pour aller
sur des marchés illégaux
que pour aller sur des forums
extrêmement discutables,
mais 95% de la bande passante de Tor
est utilisée pour des activités
qui n’ont rien à voir avec le dark web.
Alors pourquoi est-ce qu’on peut
considérer que le darknet est un outil
au service des libertés ?
Les premiers promoteurs du darknet,
les principaux promoteurs du darknet,
sont ceux qui font le plus
pour le développement du darknet,
ce ne sont pas les grandes
organisations mafieuses,
c’est pas les grandes
organisations criminelles.
C’est d’abord et avant tout
les grandes organisations de journalistes,
en particulier
de journalistes d’investigation.
Une organisation
comme Reporters sans Frontières,
pour prendre l’exemple de la France,
met à disposition de ses adhérents
ce qu’ils appellent
un kit de survie numérique.
Le kit de survie numérique, une clé USB
avec un ensemble de fichiers,
ce n’est rien d’autre qu’un ensemble
d’outils pour accéder au darknet.
Pourquoi ?
Vous êtes journaliste de guerre,
vous êtes journaliste d’investigation,
y compris dans nos pays démocratiques.
Vous avez besoin de protéger vos sources.
Vous avez besoin
de vous protéger vous-même.
Vous devez garantir à vos sources
le fait que, quoi qu’il se passe,
il sera impossible, malgré la publication
de votre papier, de remonter à lui,
de remonter [inaudible].
Le darkenet, en ce sens, est un outil
qui permet à ces grandes
associations de journalistes
de donner à leurs adhérent
les moyens d’exercer leur métier
dans des conditions
de sécurité raisonnables.
J’ai mis ici également WikiLeaks
ou bien [inaudible]
Le darknet est un outil au service
de la lutte contre les abus des puissants.
WikiLeaks a révélé, quoi qu’on puisse
penser de l’évolution de Wikileaks
au cours des années récentes,
WikiLeaks a dénoncé des faits
qui, autrement,
n’auraient jamais pu être dénoncés.
Mais ça va beaucoup plus loin :
les grands médias
- par exemple le Washington Post,
vous trouverez la même chose
dans les grands médias français -
mettent à la disposition des populations
des outils de leaks.
C’est un drop, c’est rien d’autre
qu’un outil qui va utiliser le darknet,
sur lequel vous pouvez
déposer des informations
qui ensuite sont mises
à disposition des journalistes.
Les Panama Papers, les LuxLeaks, etc.
Toutes ces fuites qui nous ont permis
de mettre en évidence, en l’occurrence,
les abus des puissants,
n’ont été possible que grâce au darknet,
que par parce que,
dans un certain nombre de cas,
uniquement parce que les lanceurs
d’alerte se savaient protégés
par l’existence d’un réseau anonymisant.
En ce sens, le darknet est un outil
au service de la liberté d’information,
mais c’est aussi, une fois encore,
un outil au service de la lutte
contre les abus des puissants.
Plus grave, plus important évidemment,
le darknet est un outil au service
de la dissidence politique.
Vous êtes un dissident politique
dans un pays dictatorial.
Mais comme vous avez besoin
de vous protéger,
pour mener à bien votre lutte,
pour arriver à rassembler.
des partenaires,
pour renforcer votre lutte
vous avez besoin.de communiquer
de manière anonyme.
En ce sens, effectivement,
le darknet est un outil au service
de la dissidence politique.
Je prends l’exemple ici de quelqu’un
qui est devenu un mythe, évidemment,
car il a été exécuté par le régime syrien,
mais il y a des dizaines et des dizaines
d’autres activistes sur internet
qui ont pu être arrêtés parce que l’usage,
la capacité qu’ils avaient à dissimuler
leurs actions était insuffisante.
Le fait de disposer d’outils anonymisants,
le fait de pouvoir passer
par le darknet pour s’organiser,
permet de lutter
contre les abus dictatoriaux.
Je parle de dissidence politique,
mais on peut aussi parler
de dissidence sociétale.
Ce que j’appelle dissidence sociétale,
c’est par exemple
le fait que dans un certain
nombre de pays d’Afrique,
l’homosexualité est condamnée.
En Ouganda, par exemple,
vous êtes susceptible d’être condamné
à une peine de prison à vie.
Pourtant,
si vous êtes homosexuel en Afrique,
comme dans n’importe quelle communauté,
vous avez besoin de vous organiser,
vous avez besoin d’échanger avec vos pairs
vous avez besoin de d’échanger
pour organiser tel ou tel événement,
ou tout simplement pour former communauté.
Les darknets sont au service
de cette dissidence sociétale.
Grâce au darknet (vous avez ici
un exemple qui vient en fait d’un darkweb)
grâce à ça, vous pouvez vous organisez.
Vous pouvez vivre
votre dissidence sociétale
à l’abri du regard, évidemment,
des services de sécurité.
Mais il y a plus grave encore,
beaucoup plus grave,
c’est la lutte
contre la surveillance de masse.
Depuis le 11 septembre,
les États-Unis d’abord, avec la NSA,
ont mis en place un vaste système
de surveillance de masse.
Un système de surveillance de masse,
ça veut dire que nous sommes tous
- souvenez vous de la polémique
sur la mise en place des fameuses
boîtes noires en France,
c’est parti des États-Unis mais
c’est maintenant évidemment généralisé -
ça veut dire que nous sommes
tous surveillés.
Nous sommes surveillés indirectement,
c’est pas des gens qui sont
en train de nous regarder,
mais ça veut dire tout simplement que
l’ensemble de nos activités sur Internet
sont susceptibles d’être observées
par des services de sécurité.
C’est un changement fondamental
dans l’histoire de l’Homme.
C’est la première fois
dans l’histoire de l’humanité
qu’un gouvernement
a la possibilité de surveiller
l’ensemble de sa population.
Pour un service de renseignement,
je parle de service
de renseignement démocratique,
je ne suis pas en train de parler
d’un quelconque complot
pour prendre le pouvoir,
pour un service de renseignement,
un service de sécurité,
le fait d’avoir une vue sur ce que fait
l’ensemble de sa population,
c’est naturellement pain béni.
Ils font ça pour notre sécurité.
Une fois encore, il ne s’agit pas là
de mettre en place un système de contrôle
de manière à vérifier tout ce qu’on fait
et à nous orienter,
Il s’agit tout simplement d’essayer
d’assurer notre sécurité.
Il n’en reste pas moins que les abus
de cette surveillance de masse
nous mènent à une société
qui est excessivement inquiétante,
nous mènent à une organisation
du corps social
qui est extrêmement perturbante.
On sait depuis longtemps,
parce qu’il y a eu beaucoup d’études
qui ont été menées,
que quand on se sait surveillé,
on a tendance à modifier
son comportement,
ceci de manière éventuellement
et souvent inconsciente.
On a tendance à transformer
son comportement
pour qu’il tende à aller dans le sens
de ce que l’on pense
que le surveillant souhaite.
C’est insidieux, c’est inconscient,
mais c’est une réalité.
Et c’est cette réalité que nous sommes
en train de vivre depuis quelques années.
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire que progressivement,
là ou nous vivions dans un environnement
qui était un environnement
relativement libre,
nous nous dirigeons
vers ce que Deleuze, Foucault et Burroughs
ont appelé la société de contrôle.
Son expression la plus marquée
actuellement, c’est évidemment
le système de crédit social chinois
qui passe beaucoup
par le contrôle sur Internet.
Si vous agissez conformément au souhait
du parti, vous gagnez des points.
Si inversement vous êtes déviant,
vous perdez des points.
Si vous gagnez des points,
vous avez des avantages
dans les transports, les hôpitaux.
Si vous en perdez,
vous êtes évidemment pénalisés,
vous ne pouvez plus vous déplacer
ou moins vous déplacer.
À tout moment,
un gouvernement est capable
de vous dire :
« oui, toi tu es conforme,
tu peux faire ça,
toi, tu n’es pas conforme,
tu ne peux pas faire ça. »
La société qui est en train
de se mettre en place,
penser que ceci restera
cantonné à des pays comme la Chine,
c’est se leurrer.
Il s’agit pas de penser, de dire qu’on va
avoir un crédit social similaire en France
demain matin, ce n’est pas du tout ça.
Simplement la tendance insidieuse
qui est actuellement engagée,
c’est celle-là.
On a vécu, jusqu’à récemment,
dans ce que les grands
philosophes français
appelaient la société disciplinaire,
c’est-à-dire que nous sommes punis
quand nous nous trompons,
nous sommes enfermés,
la société d’enfermement, la prison.
Demain, comme Deleuze
l’a noté dès la fin des années 80,
nous nous dirigeons
vers une société de contrôle.
Une société de contrôle ouvert,
c’est-à-dire que nous sommes libres,
mais nous sommes tout le temps contrôlés.
Nous sommes tout le temps
sous surveillance.
C’est très exactement
ce qui est en train de se passer.
Alors, pour reprendre ce que disait
Deleuze à l’époque,
l’important, ce sera peut-être de trouver
des vacuoles de non-communication,
des interrupteurs
pour échapper au contrôle.
Au sein de cette société de contrôle,
nos mois, nos espaces de liberté,
dépendrons de notre capacité
à créer ces vacuoles.
Le darknet, c’est précisément
l’un de ces interrupteurs.
C'est précisément l'une de ces vacuoles.
En ce sens, c’est pas darknet
qu’il devrait s’appeler,
mais bien Freenet.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)